hey Mary here once again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and let us begin with a gentlemen's duel
to go in and only one returns and you
don't have to be an ego Montoya to hold
a grudge but practice your kills or rest
you end up like poor Rufio lookie lookie
i guess you can fight with the best of
them January thirteenth if you're into
sword fighting but looking for a high
res option pick up metal gear rising
revengeance for PC take on the four
Desperados and rip out the spine like
repair unit of your enemies and crush it
in the palm of your hands like the
predator ride and don't mess around
pretend that revengeance is a real word
this games out now
also this week great games don't just
exist they expand like the latest
expansion of Europa Universalis for
conquest of paradise the expansion
allows you to send your ships off to the
west and discover new world and Native
American nations but be careful with
your taxes or the colonies will throw
your tea in the ocean don't act like you
didn't see that schoolhouse rock that's
called taxation without representation
and it divide and conquer january
fourteenth now I fight for the people
another game that's revisiting American
history this week is assassin's creed
liberation HD which is making its way to
pc xbox 360 and ps3 if this title sounds
vaguely familiar to you it's because it
was already released but on the Vita
alright visit New Orleans in the 1700s
as avalyne a free woman who uses her
high society status to get near her
targets and assassinate them fascinatin
style january fourteenth
finally enjoy the brutal and beautiful
Banner Saga a role-playing game with
spectacular Viking animations paired
with fantastic scores by
grammy-nominated composer Austin wintery
the saga begins january fourteenth for
further details visit gamespot's new
releases page release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week
you